Hi ladies.
Hello.
Hi.
How are you today?
I'm doing pretty good.
This is so weird.
It's so weird.
This new world?
Hi Sara.
I know, it's like a whole new world,
also it's kind of a dream world
'cause I feel like I'm always with Sara
and it's so nice
to not have to be sitting next to you, Sara.
(Drew laughs)
I've been such big fans of yours for such a long time
and you guys have really had tremendous longevity
in your career.
And we also have in common that we all started
at a young age and you know,
what do you think that maybe you know now about life,
the industry, all of it, that maybe you didn't know then?
So many things (laughs).
Well, one thing, this sounds like a bit of a cheesy thing
but someone told us
while we were probably 10 years into our career,
they said a career is a marathon, it's not a sprint.
And I think in the beginning of our career,
we worried that like every decision we were making
could make or break us,
and we're 20 years into our career
and I still feel like making mistakes
is one of the most significant ways to grow and to change.
And I want to do this forever.
And so, I wish I'd been a little easier on myself
when I was younger.
It's so true.
And I've been the kind of person
that thought every decision was life or death.
I took everything so seriously, the tiniest little detail
of which I would obsess on was make or break.
I think for us the last four or five years
our focus has been on making sure we tell the whole story
you know, we aren't perfect
and we haven't always been great at everything we do
and we weren't always awesome people
and we made lots of mistakes along the way
and had bad haircuts along the way.
And that's okay.
Those are all the things that make up who we are.
And yeah, I think that's been the biggest gift
of the last few years.
Maybe that's just age, too
but looking back has allowed us to sort of be less difficult
and hard on ourselves about that time.
Was there a moment in your lives
where you just thought you know what, life is good?
We have made it.
We're in a moment where we're having
a lack of where we need to go.
And a moment of where we've been.
When I think about when it is
that I knew that we had made it
there's a few things that pop into my head,
but one is my grandmother had this beautiful
stainless steel fridge
and she never put anything on it, nothing,
like there was never a thing,
not one magnet, nothing,
but she kind of collected some of our clippings
and put it up on the fridge.
And I just remember, you know
really thinking that if our grandma was taking it seriously
that we should take it seriously.
But then I think about really big things
like playing on the Oscar stage.
I mean, we didn't think
there was never a point in our adolescence
or even in our twenties when I would have ever even
said out loud, oh, one day I want to play on the Oscars.
That was just not something
that we would have imagined for ourselves.
And I just feel so glad
and really grateful that we had so much support
from our family because we've had a pretty cool run.
Well, speaking of family,
your mom is involved in your foundation.
Will you quickly tell me about what she has brought to it?
So our mom is a therapist.
She works with teenagers and couples
and she deals with relationships and she loves the work
but she needs to blow off steam.
So she started doing pottery
and she ended up being a natural
and she was inspired to do something with the pots
that would benefit our foundation.
And so she made pots that have our hairstyles
from over the years.
Yeah, we put up a, you know, this fundraiser for a week
and Mom made 26 pots and we raised 15 grand.
And every year, my mom donates to the foundation,
she's a monthly donator
but she kicked us off the year we started it.
She donated $10,000
which let us send 10 LGBTQ kids to LGBTQ summer camp.
And yeah, my mom's a big supporter and it's, you know,
it's one of our most favorite things that we get to do,
which is give back to our community
and raise money for women and girls, so.
Yeah, your foundation is so important
and I just want to thank you
and High School, by the way, this is one of the first books
I've ever seen in this format.
And it's a true original as are you guys,
so it's ever so fitting that it is so unique
and High School is available now in paperback.
And thank you guys so much from the nineties to the aughts,
to the now 2021.
So wonderful to be living in your world.
Thank you, Tegan and Sara.
(upbeat music)